[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome bake your research and
focus on gretsch a user guide they
have stellar panel to talk about
troubleshooting in datacenter in had
and programs games that a machine
learning and enjoy my daddy today and
this music or bolt researchers in  the
adaptive systems en interactive google
microsoft en alzo bennassar sonny with a
post-doc researcher and mobility and
networking thanks to you before coming
two of you ever so on your working
on research to improve real-time systems
nou met de help and you a machine
learning solidarity with your business has
about this workshop industry tricks watson
born about my you do
yes so my research live at the
intersection of you him in en
machine intelligence
and basic gray working with dat is
systems that combine both humus and
machines together to solve  the most
complex problems at
ibfd and wie focus mainly in component-based
motion piping system sorry no words
systems that her meal modern
compound working together and the reason
why who does such a thing b house in the last
us there have been many adventures in in
the world for building single cask
matured and in component seems for jump
up to date action component sourcing
processing and one je polis business
together into  a bigger system blackberry
sambalsaus driving car or a factory
pipeline am there completely new
challenge at minutes face and saw
system engineers a soa searchers
en coutinho troubleshooting and
debugging is one of the main challenges
and systems engineers with this this in
order 20 zijn bij der leeuw systems  and
20th en word wim program next
soy sauce the idea bicky's adjuster does
that very well what beautiful best mergez his
heels run but what a modular nature
and systems and lie modular die kim
feedback en already so much in manure
concept sharm so my background is a
compromise  robotics background and
dropping of the minigames breathing
glaxo driving car software die roon
soft  ware and if ik a file is there
about you mission critical safety critical
pieces of hardware and software working
together under way i researched and
screen environments and queen of furry
migration and field which requires market
apple expertise doorstep of the frank
domains to come together
who it  lek electrical engineering
computer science and then as a minus op
specializations so always like i know
which its just because of the social
nature en de place de science of the closet
and deeper and deeper breaks in sap in the
modules swedish because it allows for
the vision  of labor and one team side
economy on the cambuur responsible for
me and the gunner and spot for
years to come software company and this is how it
works
and and the developers for black you have
a cup of tea philippi leak
nominal output or also specific module
is  one and death sauce for leaks
application of expertise domain
expertise to be actually yes plein and the
course like i know there are many  many
more news with you will be puja there in
such royal christams
this channel like i after withdrawal way
switch app the local corpse in the moor
new level one mina app design this for
my husband also chop wood build covers
like give year grow keep on
improving the  smart new in which your
budget into a bit last vote you find
them bad puddings
like i know the crying widgets running
and then you find a equality so the
section are not already sown in the bizarre
that give you that over all 6 vote
anyway by the  local marjo lisbloem
really well on its own
so setting in individual in my hen
per er became my micro system chest
yes absolutely and then this is a labor
lasted honor of amina and that he her
absurd and the so she again you question
behind my time and  in systems which is
well packed
to that this has happened you can
so researchers tackling that
problem to kino
individually nigel switcher necessary in
arc systems
on how you dressing dat  nl-logo i think
so mainly you think about our gi
have that funky cold day was a web
of a mormon mid
prospective so cool whip black this is
her networking the hague-logo
de van teams er managing disadvantages there are
so wonderful the altena not  on your round
photo albert iphone jury and zo service
keyboard in the functions any of them and
managing ears configure the van paris
networks oh and i in the interview the
jews were great zo i go a period of
hoarse and and systems lady handle it now is
busy crossing the involved in
derbyshire seems like theory
yes and he would be in words right now
so we caught they mothers find you
actually is one that woman i keep him from
secession networking with the
players
we do ff last ok soju cable people
and  systems and components and systems
that semi-individual jumpsuit in the
rent and the new got to try the
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] me research respect the
idea the forest de keith mick in happy
singles koran of bill
bloomingdale evaporation the crime
and was a human
yes so big picture
watch king peter baltus hyatt house zo
and read in networking tick then be
difficult where is maybe yourself manager
nexus coming up right there be mine to
eliminate the germs of the dance music
and and other  idea of home mix at the stroke
of sociology and there is the drawing
from the high manager be with
inclusion so a warmth shot de of
teams and then juli 13th responsibility
in the top samantha place for time time
if it out of this is not something  i
should be looking out and why did some
of you and personnel go to
war in all its forms perspective and
security directs that day
customize your mind to be responsible
for installing something inside derrière
citigo fabia is there
crumpler as a crash and who is wiser
cream is logical for me and for
figura is bcm that camp was there so I
only sensing this piece and researchers
from further in fine fraud beyo  nd my
music home in had husband i have me so
is my mother calls family that this
system our perspective that cm no or
problem keep it your address formula
you will there a view properties of
machine learning system that make this
work of flex self healing  god self
managing feather
little bit more difficult than in
traditional software for a shampoo
who will that in machine learning it is
barry common to say what you're
component is thanks 5% great and that
carries going to be a 5 percent worse and
that 3  is aan certainty relating to this
comment and the question is what you
have all this working together and you
have this continium of quality where
everything the slack and fixering and the
sametime golden your problem in tholen
system
this is one aspect and in that aspect is
the  often at youtube
sangha is at the architecture odessa je
noor pushed the often at a cake just
a tip and the cisco live in i win
components and one camp at a
center line of  which also becomes of the
other kamp anne there might be the
feedback loops en complex int single mens
between the is that create artifex
of the components is
kicks
sorry rubp legible impression and pans and
in order to so so enjoy trancoso
reading tools which means that we need to
generate office vectro analyzes do
two wagons impressions and what we do
de in our work is that we try to
generate is  perfect back to normal is
with my li introducing people in the
lure in order to good use the coast of
al troubleshooting zo dossier brewers
then he had a genius time in a time
twinta menthol de pyxis what they can in
their voice
that is goal is again  that we providers
and proteas from tool crowdsourcing
workers online subject and fascinated scan
check the output of the machine learning
component week en fix this output and
ben je integrate it back  into this is nam
execution and this way we can understand
what happens if you were able to really
implement
the specs and this comes where i point
to do system
designer  prospective what the
title i think you're working on in gouda
presented detector
yes to one of the things were doing
is that leaks in big live software
pipelines the relationship parameters
where i nice fine duotank awesome
free floating plums cherries could be a
good choice  it could be unlocked machine
french
what is also all surely you
communicate and black leather what gold
records she left between various
more you were looking at like you coming
up we this matter reasoning approach
which is already present so chardo in the
background
als de  system is running and and the
analogy with graham is that this matter
using more new giveaway i make a
die via coaching environments league member
c one com  puter feels like a nicer than
the put this one to the more jobs running
of the
system zodiac now for your party color
bag the the champion that's available
chance gets all the pics
the frank ical import comes a little
begging you're my youth work give  you a
manner that you're not expected before
i'm more light en sipke sometimes more
you may be contacted
howie can
ship the configuration and put there you click
on the teams that the citizen or the system
cares about like i know that you have
this new jersey minimum news
deathmatch lakedance i use it never
succeed is massive intention on the this
much is ok my party  and then all these leaks
preferences and constraints be rather
than i hart can spencer with the derby
schaf constraints can be respected in
real time to work renkum
that will him in this project jesse grill
in a water bottle empty in sea and why and
where you might see and application of
tap beer isec mission critical
a super handsome like in on your own
organic apples to the grab xoom bbc
so every day so if you can they said
something to search engine and the
search engine decides to give you a
graph  search with a capital give you
enjoyed pranking minutes
no dat aspirin knock you feel like and
part 1
yes you of new be liked system
is to during wartime article oeh wat
new savior
tick is something which almost like your
i point one second your soul
mire you  were such measures that show
ok but then put me this is
guide that video instead the right size
so put the print head an application
that serve redbull robotics can this
server driving car driving from the helm
in foursome tiroler and so walk duran
duran hmm the highway mim  -pi highway
it's fine for mortgage as much time is
the latest monomino decisions and
and find be slightly deal in now hang
of all my side have a sweet year in america
this scenario and relaxing the studio high
speed and some body style and the great
fairy harding franka electric rail 5
perfect for example rich
weavers
via for your car safe driving car
software to educate before
they cover the luxury nice detail margin eh treasure
and now that's also very critical
be very accurate in the decision that
make sure you ben nu plan context
european requirements van light in china
curaçao can change on  the fly drive en
and this is why you want to change the
stems of bing rated bad guy spot
systems and usually designed in this
light of the app which case scenario and
who want fix the premium crossbeak now because
public in do so with the reasoning
around systems
high peak is real-time veins hi and and
in in die dit xampp earlier bellino
waiting for web search
net string netsh de grecian yes pff
driving car can him tiger consequences
ec  ht zo mee in
siebes yes yes yes bed next to
menu work in an machine learning system
but you can also contribution to the
field
interesting question and nose inside
warnertv de we dit zo
elisense is a representation of the virtual
machine rigid its alibis papers was
a time machine learning to eat i
think i in the agenda then we will get it
every time for the people samsung
keyboard widget and my koeka tyler is
there after that is a new word of
greeting pictures and systems supplies
houses convention get is also quite a bit  is
your conclusion and measurement
the concierge well the wifi is for such one
and my word prononce take no
opinions from us go get the first pc
and nuts
privacy policy will be in she went
after your privacy manisa word we care
just i will know you  that have been
changed built in
the form of this to suck i in design
berg systems based on the me will de am
so i think whiskey and diana printing machine
ring of jamin at some point google site
machine learning for everything
this is a necessary necessaria
possible smit-kroes with what now casting
to goal of this research is one in
a perfect worlds site from china
circle
de ramp leem en de datacenter situation
of the notice binary code for web
search
what is  it look like must is the world
like you might be successful the
efforts and research
preview can it and in for me is
something I have a theory about after discount
if there is knowledge no matter sleek
start measurement in arnhem in the counter
hotel is so we  the layout clothing
sporting i will live organism
and then i will become there during training
ideal
best more barium east of the
goal is to build rua do and the newspapers
borea so
systems that can operate in the rio red
and that can be ready to in helping  you
mens sewing der mast campus pro along
now you also have to bio again the time
how you do die your article foundations
in order to so so with will if not
prepared tools and running
yes impr  essie actor tous les oil type
processes so
the inca to have no to target in influence
in our eyes at weather engineering state and
that yes infrastructure so that not all
ports you system to become
introspective
in oobleck oui oui oui allo in which spire
pipe this site  your goal of being able
to great intelligence pettneu
inteligence is rio i it is not in to
respect and i this channel
questionmark it's often be able to now all
this time this such there timeless so nervous
and that line itself and so we go idea  to
express to your computer your i am to
be smeared cure and in addition to
the lion on the introspection and
self-awareness and also be a word to let
you know to the kool dairy queen
i do now while i laughed and
computational i it  is i also a
family make a decision well but you
have to with it kikwit conference do my
order the have al thing of mission and
near to make of in the decision that that
never became conference on so this is the
old this real cha  llenge is from
bus station theory and machine learning
and and josh spot in her intelligence in
general and coming back in this spot i
know more prevalent in system designed
by gecko spot
we laughed cia word in which [ __ ]
gruff voice case
beautiful and elegant in  in myself we have 8
years in prison a lot of work they also know what
is enormous bring another tip line
of annona never I do the known known
space so that name and this is not
possible for them to make a decision and
they should not realize a  human being
with in the look sure not realize and
drops becomes or the system and and the
esteem just a box relatively gram
kale black rhino avenue cult site
staff brian guys and drones and jackson
are all that is is drunk with can become
watchman arthur yes
thank  you each of you come in the race
and rally of an educational ferme
all the more and in addition tanks i can and
thank you for coming to the fashion and
researching focusing motion became lex man
[Applause]